Anyone looking at a bubble--
it seems to make them happy.
They offer such amazing
potential for engineering.
They're part gas.
They're part liquid.
They float.
And yet they're
solid enough that you
can manipulate
them to do things.
Our main focus is
finding better ways
to deliver drugs to the
body, though at the moment,
for the vast majority of
diseases, if you're given
a drug, you're given it
as a pill or an injection.
And it goes throughout
your bloodstream.
Every cell in your body, pretty
much, is exposed to that drug.
If I say that the
complexity of what we do
is the same as the complexity
if you were designing a car,
I wouldn't be exaggerating.
I love London.
It's always fun to wander around
and find quirky bits of London,
and just shoot for myself.
I didn't really know
anything about chemotherapy.
I had no idea that it's so
toxic that the nurses have
to wear protective clothing
while they're injecting you.
You are poisoning the body.
You're being systematically,
seriously poisoned.
What we're trying
to do is create
a means of delivering
those drugs just where they
need to go.
For example, in
the case of cancer,
we need to get those drugs just
to the cells within the tumour.
We don't want them
going everywhere else.
You're so badly poisoned that
your immune system doesn't
work.
Even a cold can kill you.
And in fact, the
chemotherapy scared me
more than the idea
of having cancer.
The bubbles do a
number of things.
Firstly, they act
as a great vehicle
for putting the drugs in.
The drug stays within the
bubble until we release it,
and so it avoids
it going everywhere
else around the body.
Some of our bubbles that
we make are magnetic,
so we can actually drag them
into a location using a magnet.
We then use ultrasound to get
the bubbles to start vibrating.
The vibration of
the bubble actually
helps to pump the drug
further into the tissue
than it would otherwise go.
We get a much more effective
distribution of the drug
throughout the tumour.
The first time that
worked in an experiment,
and we got this huge increase
in the amount of drug delivered,
that was tremendously exciting.
I have chronic fatigue,
because my body was so badly
hurt by the chemotherapy.
If there was a way of
doing this differently,
then I could have
had my life back.
It makes me jealous to
think other people might
be able to be treated for the
same kind of cancer as I had,
and they wouldn't
have to contend
with what I have to
contend with now.
It's hard.
We've got lots of talented
people doing maths and physics,
doing brilliantly, and not
realising that they can have
such an exciting career
applying that in engineering,
and somehow we've
got to change that.
It does allow you to
change people's lives
and the way the world works.
And there are so
many huge problems
that need addressing
in the world.
Engineering has got a
massive role to play in that,
and the more people
that realise that,
and that we can encourage to
come and solve these problems,
the better.